[Music]
are you sweeties and sweetie pies
and we're back taste buds yes podcast
back in action so uh
i'm excited uh coming off the heels of
the victory the drubbing of 62 to 38
uh oreo over chips ahoy i'm excited i'm
taking momentum with me
into the second episode um i will say
there's as much passion involved here
would you agree
yeah this is uh this this next uh debate
uh is yet another great food debate that
sal and i had
uh just in regular friendship that went
on for
i believe hours i i believe it was a
weekend
yeah possibly a whole weekend uh it was
revisited quite a bit
throughout the week uh after it was
initially
uh after it initially transpired um
and we want to take it to the public
that's what this show's all about taking
these private food debates
to the public because we're very
passionate about the foods we love
we have opinions and voices opinions and
voices
and we like to pull the people in around
us to get their opinions that's right
and hear their voices uh something we do
all the time anyway
yeah and we're like this is this should
be shared this should be it's fun
and there's a there's a there is a real
special feeling and
because we've we've been on both sides
of the debate coin where you took a
winner you take
you take an l and there is there's
something really delightful about a win
and it's something really biting
and it gets under your skin when you
take a loss would you say
well yeah i think you're saying that
because i've taken more losses than you
i wasn't
i wasn't but if you want to be cynical
out of the gate you get that's you
i'm ready because i think that you have
a shiftiness to you
that you put under the guise of this
like hey i'm just a
sweet kid kind of thing yeah okay i
think you do
well i i i no because you know i mean it
doesn't mean that i won't dig down deep
and when i need to defend my food
choices
i i am a sweet kid but will i i do think
you're so i have a co
sometimes i have an arrogance with you
when i feel
like i really know the right answer
because i i
i because i have with me the confidence
that i know that
the polls are going to indicate that i
am going to be backed
uh you know and and and and if i'm ever
in one where i really think it's a
coin toss or i am maybe an underdog
maybe i don't have that much confidence
maybe i don't have that much arrogance
you're picking up on the shiftiness now
because
this is yet this is going to be another
this is going to be another just real
sad
sack for you you're just going to be zen
zach
but let me be clear let me be clear
about something if
if either of us uh loses a debate
which will happen uh it doesn't mean
that changes our opinion or
we're submitting to the idea that the
other person is right
i lost the oreo chips ahoy debate
i still know that i'm right and sal is
wrong
and it's not my fault that a bunch of
people agreed with his opinion
and they all have the same dumb opinion
i can't i can't fix that i'm not here to
fix that i'm not the president sure no
you don't know of anything
no okay uh so i just want to make that
clear
it is la it's crystal it is crystal
right uh and i will say
usually the majority uh something is
popular for a reason the majority of
people
there's an indicator there especially on
like semi landslides or what have you
like that
but i will say that there's been times
where the minority is absolutely right
like even if you pick you applied to
anything a movie
that you loved that and and people just
don't get it and the majority of people
pan the movie
but then you feel the movie was just
great and there's a
section of people that get it and you
click and whatnot this is a little bit
more
left to people's taste buds
it is and and i think kind of taste buds
are connected to us
uh like uh in a biological way
and and and i think like much like
shakira's hips i don't know if taste
buds lie
i don't know if they lie uh so i will
say that that the polls here i think
would indicate you know somewhat of a an
answer we could hang our hats on
uh you're right cause all the best
things are the most popular thing
i know i was making a case against that
you're right every big blockbuster is
one of the best movies
well you're right well there you go
right there maybe a movie was not a good
maybe it was an apple to a lemon on that
one but
but movies but i'm saying taste buds see
here you go sweet salty sour
bitter umami which is the savory right
she's sweet and salty so you get five
major taste areas on your tongue so
oh wow and check it out i didn't realize
that the taste areas on your tongue
are in different sections yeah that is
weird
that's wild so the sweet is what you're
tasting with the tip of your tongue
the salty the outer rim the sour is the
two outside
i guess is where the receptors are
really kicking in i didn't know that the
bitter in the back and then the umami is
everything combined now
that could also just be a graphic made
by anyone and i'm just putting this
information out
it says taste areas on the human side no
but that is it and who knew that
i didn't so you're learning things we're
learning we're learning things
we're learning things so i wonder if i
took something sweet
and then touched the sweet receptor area
being indicated here
and then i took something sweet and i
touched it by the bitter receptor in the
back according to this here
if i am going to taste it differently
i don't think so i think what that's
telling you is that's the area the
tongue that
that picks up the most of the particular
flavor
that's like why when i probably when you
when you have something bitter
it it hits you and it feels like it hits
you in the back exactly yes yes
it's not necessarily salty you always
start to get watery over here or sour
you're like
and it's on the side that's wild that
like if you think about it it's true
yeah that is true never knew it they
didn't teach out in school it is
no why they don't teach you anything
good in school but what i'm saying here
is this is
a five-tiered biological system full of
endings nerves
ligaments all the stuff that's in your
mouth and uh so i'm saying that so
people respond to that and i'm saying
that
we might have the polls might be more
accurate than you think uh
i'm i have no regard for the polls
and i refuse to respect him in any way
but it's a nice gimmick for the show
let's see you sing that tune when you
win big you're going to be like the
polls
know what the polls know of course i
will this is electoral college versus
popular vote
whatever one agrees with me i'm gonna go
with uh
but here's the thing let's get where are
we at here time wise mike
all right six minutes in we're about
ready to drop the the twitter poll for
today's argument which is ladies and
gentlemen
better bagel cinnamon raisin
or everything and
to eat it is out there it
is live now would you like to tell them
the ship the ship that you're on right
now has a couple of hundred thousand
holes on it
would you like to name the ss ship
you're on because you were on the assets
chips ahoy before
proudly i'm on the everything bagel i
mean sorry
[ __ ] i'm on the cinnamon raisin ship i'm
on ship
cinnamon raisin to cinnamon bun island
baby
because it's a wonderful bagel and
that's what you want first thing in the
morning
and that's how this argument started we
once again were on vacation
right we sound like we just we are just
like
like robin leech like we are just
hopping around
world travelers like we're just like
where are we on vacation when this one
cropped up
yeah we have a hot air balloon we travel
around what happened was
there's a pandemic and we have a lot
more time yeah yeah it's the whole
it's been fizzy well we saved vacations
when we say vacation yeah
we have not gone to a tropical island we
do not
we are not at a resort we are not even
on a plane i think what we mean is
that we are spending some time together
yeah yeah but it was a morning
it was an early morning and uh we were
talking about bagels
and uh i believe there were only
everything bagels in the house
because i went out and got you sending
raisins after that you didn't though
you didn't let's not lie thomas english
muffin cinnamon raisins you still
as a as a nice little [ __ ] you is what
he did
because he wouldn't bring the actual
thing i wanted into the house he
was like i got you your thing and then
you couldn't be mad because he would it
was still nice
but it was passive aggressive they
didn't have cinnamon rolls but sal was
in charge of buying bagels and and i
said do we have any cinnamon raisin and
he said no there's only everything
and i said never mind i don't want one
and that's how this whole thing
you ever heard someone say that on the
heels of this everything bagels
have you ever heard i mean you're gonna
get killed worse than chips ahoy
than oreo slaughter chips ahoy we'll see
the everything bagel
it's in the name babe everything it's
everything everybody wants it's got a
little bit of error
it represents everything wrong with this
country
look at it it's it's indulgence
it's throw it all into one place you're
gonna separate you're gonna throw the
indulgence card on everything as opposed
to a cinnamon raisin
cinnamon raisin sweet just i mean just
over the top look at the top of that
bagel they
dumped it looks like they dumped a
buffet on the top of that bag
it looks heavenly it looks gluttonous is
what it looks like it doesn't you can't
have a lot of seeds
and that's gluttonous it looks
gluttonous to me if there was a billion
bagels i would say on a hole
they look gluttonous but the topping of
the bagel is not gluten and i'm going to
say it too cause i've seen it in your
house
the everything bagel seasoning it's for
trash people
oh my god you're gonna need to get
24-hour security on you
you're gonna need a security detail
you're insulting
most of the globe i'm not even saying in
the united states or new york or what
have you
you are throwing out bombs right now my
friend it's a trash it's like it's like
okay you crashy thing to have around i
like what you did i like what you did
you did what they do in rap battles you
used what i was gonna use against you
and you tried to use it against me
like you would be rabbit and it's not
gonna happen all right
everything bagel topping is so good they
took it off the bagel
and they sell it on its own they sell it
and and i will tell you i will
i will name names because a lot of
people make it but trader joe's
they really know what they're doing over
there i love
i love everything it's called everything
but the bagel
right it's so great what a genius idea
they had a board meeting
and they all went to lunch that day
feeling good about themselves because
that's some name
and let me tell you i apply it is a good
name i'll give you that i apply
everything but the bagel seasoning
salads eggs dishes
chips i i i when i when i don't have it
i put it on
on the cream cheese i mix it into the
cream cheese
you can put it on almost anything you
know what i've done and everyone does
this too
when i'm done with an everything bagel
and there's all the uh the ones that
fell off the bagel in the plate i go
like this i go like this
and i pick that up like it is like
i just pick it up and i just and i ate
it all i don't leave a seed in the plate
when i'm done with my everything
the plate looks like it's clean it's i'm
done with the everything bagel
it's a mixture of poppy it's a mixture
of sesame it's a little bit of salt it's
a little bit of garlic
it's got every onion powder i mean come
on it's
all the flavors you talk about the taste
buds in your mouth you talk about taste
buds you want to talk about the name of
this podcast we just saw the taste buds
are all over sweet savory bread
this is banging on all cylinders your
tongue is having enough there's no sweet
there's no
there's no one bit of sweet in that
stuff oh really but what about when i
put on some cream cheese with it
what about when i put these isn't sweet
oh really oh talk to blueberry cream
cheese and get back to me
you're putting now i'm getting my whole
my whole mouth disgusting
my whole mouth is having a party you're
not supposed to treat your whole mouth
together at once you wouldn't treat your
whole body
to anything all at once you're insane
you hear of a four-handed massage
oh come on why is that you want even
more stimulation of course the whole
thing
explains something to you about
everything seasoning okay because i
can't tell you how many times i've
watched
you know gordon ramsay or jamie oliver
and they are they're always throwing the
everything bagel seasoning into their
dishes
no oh okay never it's
garbage food it's not a thing it's not
good you know what it is you know what
it is i'm gonna tell you what it is i'll
tell you what it is
it's like aioli it's like when you go
somewhere and they go ah
and they try to sound fancy they go with
your turkey sandwich with a pesto garlic
aioli you're trash
you put [ __ ] into mayonnaise and you try
to make it and you think it's fancy
because you don't know any better
you don't know any better why are you
just describing food
isn't food just made of other things and
combined to make new things
no no no okay no all right okay well but
there's people let me tell you something
there's poppy bagels
the sesame bagels there's salt bagels
there's garlic bagels
and there's onion bagels and people have
and like all of those types of bagels
those are really like
really like on the mount rushmore of
bagels why i'll take an
onion bagel over and everything bagel
i'd rather i like a streamlined bagel
i it's too much no it's not it's first
thing
do i want do i want to do first thing in
the morning do i want
one bagel with the benefits of five
yes i do yes i do i'm gonna eat one bit
i don't have to choose
oh my i love onion i love garlic i love
how that sesame seed tastes you ever
have a salt bagel
it's really nice that's a little heavy
but i got to be in the mood for it but a
salt bake is full
salt what everything does is it takes a
little bit of ratio of all of them and
when you take a bite
whatever you really want to feel on your
tongue for the specific bagel that's
what you're feeling
and they also you can se if you have a
good enough palate and i'm telling you
it's not for trash people if you have a
good enough palette
you can pick up on the notes that you
want to pick up on or
you could choose to taste it as a whole
and the sum of its parts are greater
than
individual it combines for a super taste
okay now let's you talk about god
because i i can't even i can't wait to
dig into the cinnamon
let's swing it over to a cinnamon raisin
let's talk about all the breakfast foods
that feature cinnamon raisin for a
reason cinnamon raisin toast
don't you apply the argument that you
used against
the oreo to the cinnamon raisin people
have memories
i'm not saying i'm not saying i take it
apart i'm saying this is a flavor
i said the oreo is used in blizzards and
shakes and ice creams and pies and crust
and you said that's not the oreo's
intention
and you can't do that and and that's
like saying i ate a burrito
and i threw away the lettuce and i said
you can't say that and now you're going
to use that same argument in defense
of the cinnamon rolls the bagel is used
i'm saying cinnamon raisin in and of
itself
is a breakfast flavor just like
blueberry is a popular
breakfast flavor okay you find it in
many breakfast dishes
the flavor of cinnamon rag and raisin is
all cinnamon
that was uh i love that my halloween
costume
the uh it's all over breakfast
you can't you you've never seen
everything
cereal you've never seen a [ __ ]
omelette with sesame seeds and poppy
seeds all through them well you haven't
seen my helmet but okay
okay you haven't seen it cinnamon raisin
permeates breakfast
and what gives you a better warmer
more breakfasty feeling than the
wonderful toasted cinnamon raisin bagel
with some cream cheese on it you can add
jelly
okay you can't put jelly on an
everything bagel and yes i tried
because you dared me to on the trip and
it was disgusting you could put
anything you want putting jelly on it
you could put anything
you want on everything you would have a
ham and cheese you could have tomatoes
scallion
i had one the other day red onion tomato
and
scallion cream cheese on and everything
blew my balls off i have no more balls
that's salty
you're talking salty you're talking
salty i'm talking sweet
breakfasty as a matter of fact i would
content
i would contend that cinnamon raisin is
way less versatile i can't have a ham
and cheese
on a cinnamon raisin bagel without a
straight up
i don't want an egg on a cinnamon raisin
either i'm talking
about the bagel standing on its own two
feet okay but i'm telling you butter
butter cream cream even jelly can go on
and everything i do it all the time
everybody bites jelly on and everything
you're getting garlic and
onion into the jelly it's disgusting
it's disgusting
it's insane and i don't believe that you
do it okay and i don't believe you do it
are you now you're just insulting my
character i've been doing this since the
day i
had an everything bagel i want everybody
to keep this in mind because
i will eat i will eat i will i will eat
i love
jelly on my bagels i love jelly with
butter and with cream cheese
alike and uh nothing stops me no no
topping on the bagel sauce me everything
does not
i exclusively choose everything bagels
and i would you put jelly on your pizza
no you might as well let me tell you
about the arguments you're making on
this part
as well would you take pizza crust from
pizza hut and put jelly on it
no no it's disgusting quags it tastes
like buttery garlicky oniony
whatever bread oh you gotta come harder
with that i'm coming hard
no you're not i'm coming hard yo you're
the i can't have it would you
i can't onion and put jelly i can't put
it on top of a sandwich
i can't have cream cheese and jelly on
my everything bagel and you're comparing
that to me putting
jelly on my pizza hut pizza no i said
would you take just the crust of the
pizza hut pizza
which is buttery garlicky oniony
flavored bread
and put jelly on it of course you
wouldn't i would with an everything
bagel i wouldn't do it with a pizza hut
slice
not a [ __ ] stop twisting my words the
crust the crust
even the pizza crust bread stick from
pizza hut a bread stick
same thing no it's not it's very similar
it's not though it's similar but i'm not
arguing the pizza hot breadstick
this is what they say what do they say
in court this is inadmissible who puts
jelly on it listen all i'm saying is
everything in the morning mike can you
google
jelly everything bagel and just see if
an image comes up because apparently
you should have a google what do they
call that when you google something
doesn't come up
i dated it i mean it's just look at it i
mean look at it
i mean you could google blood on an
everything bagel i bet you you'll find
it google it
you don't chicken internet you don't
you don't nope you don't so if you want
to just just don't just
don't go willy nilly with the arguments
because what you're doing is you're
digging yourself a hole now
listen i'm ready i'm ready everything i
want to
bagel pigs in a blanket that's not do
that with a cinnamon raisin
take a hike that's not an everything
bagel that's everything bagel seasoning
on top of pigs in a blanket
my point you could put you could put
motor oil on top of pigs in the blanket
it'd be delicious nobody's putting it
don't act like nobody's putting
cinnamon on their pizzas nobody's
putting raisins
on their pictures nobody's putting
cinnamon and raisins on it because
nobody's a sick madman like you putting
jelly on an onion bagel
it's nuts this is my point is
everything's seasoning
take the plain bagel right the plain
bagel probably most versatile which i
also eat over and everything none of us
would argue that
but you're really arguing the seasonings
of the bagels
too much and i'm telling you everything
bagel just like the oreo
is applied to look it's i mean
everything mixed in a
and a bloody mary with i've had it i've
had a bloody mary
i've had a bloody mary can i tell you
this that my mind
oh my god my mind is blown this is the
versatility of an everything seasoning
they have a bloody mary
a pickle a celery stick an olive it
looks beautiful and
they did instead of assault room they
did and everything can i tell you this
everything bagel can i tell you this go
ahead please sign
when we were on the same trip and you
had left for the day to go do something
yeah i had bloody marys with some
friends of ours that were there with me
put cinnamon on the rim oh you put that
everything bagel mix in it
you didn't yeah it was delicious but i
felt like trash while i drank it
and i mean that yeah but you i mean
selling yourself down the river
i'm not sure you know what's trash you
gotta pump sugar into your mouth
first thing in the morning when you wake
up in the morning
and it's a let me say this let me say
this please
please let me say this when you wake up
in the morning it's a cold day
it's a rainy day sunday morning
okay overcast you want to feel
warm you want to feel like you're back
oh my god oh my god you want to feel
like
cinnamon raisin martini there you go
okay with cinnamon around the river
okay okay you want to feel like you're
back home again in the
in your mother's sweet embrace maybe
and cinnamon raisin bagel is what gives
you that treat
when you want to have a cup of coffee
and you want something on the side of
that cup of coffee a cinnamon raisin
bagel compliments black coffee so
beautifully went on a hot day
when it's hot and it's too hot in the
morning that's what i want on
a piping hot day on a dog day of summer
i'm like give me
cinnamon and raisins yeah don't you
think that's much more forgiving than a
salty
mess against your palate covered in
grease is one of the main ingredients of
life
it is you're really on a hot day you
want a dehydrating bagel
no here's the thing okay i again just
like the chips ahoy
i love cinnamon raisin i love a good i
don't know no i i don't hate cinnamon
raisin i don't hate it i've had it
i my grandma used to have make cinnamon
raisin bread or toast all the time
although that was her go-to my grandma
so and i never had it but when i
went to her house she's like you want a
piece of cinnamon raisin toast you put
the butter on it
it's delicious it's in moderation it's
delicious
at the right time you tell me i wake up
from school it's a it's a
it's a freezing cold day out a nice
piece of butter on a cinnamon raisin
bagel
it gives my taste buds a pop it does but
you're asking me can if i have to have
one bagel every day for the rest of my
life or just one bagel
and and that's the bagel that exists
everything over cinnamon raisin
10 times to 100 times to one it's
everything i
can enjoy a cinnamon raisin bagel i
don't think it's disgusting
but i but i do think that i need it in
moderation i need to be kind of in the
mood for it and it's not as versatile a
bagel if i had to choose one bagel
it's going to be everything all the way
and by the way the beautiful little
scenarios little tableaus or the little
scenes you set up about an early morning
or this or that yeah you can say that
too
a beautifully toasted everything bagel
with butter
is nice with a cup of coffee too fyi i
don't wake up on a rainy day and go oh
you know what i want
onion flavor immediately uh i want
garlic flavor immediately
i don't wake up with a hot day and go
let me further dehydrate myself with the
salt
uh palette in into my mouth immediately
the picture you're painting for me is
giving me an insight into your life so
you wake up on a rainy day and you're
like get me some [ __ ] raisins asap i
need raisins cinnamon raisins
that's what you feel when it rains the
warm
i could eat a cinnamon raisin bagel with
butter or cream cheese
every single morning with my coffee
never get tired of it
ever ever ah man i can't have raisins
and cinnamon bacon
it's your beef with raisins do you do
not like to be regular what's your
i don't know believe me i'm regular i
love raisin bran
i'm just saying like a cinnamon raisin
bagel is
once in a while bagel it's a when you're
in the mood bagel
it's a hit the right spot bagel i could
also bite into a cinnamon raisin if i'm
not the moon to be like
i'm good for now i don't want it i just
don't want it like i wasn't ready for
the chewy chewy
like raisins in it and the cinnamon
cinnamon is good
cinnamon is good when you really want it
and
in the right use like cinnamon is really
nice on like a hot cocoa with a little
whipped cream
if america cinnamon is really nice and
like a beautiful baked a baked like
treat if america had a spice it would be
cinnamon do you understand that
cinnamon is the heart there's a lot of
spice and it's like the five things in
the everything no
america salt is the cinnamon the farm
apple picking baseball makes you take a
baseball
salt doesn't make you think of baseball
cinnamon makes you think of basil oh
really when i'm sitting there grab mom's
house
bring me some popcorn and cracker jacks
what's the main ingredient on those babe
what's the what's the thing you're more
excited about cracker jacks or popcorn
they both have salt no cracker jack says
caramel all the way
it is not caramel's not cinnamon there's
no it's salty
it's sweet though it's sweet it's the
sweet flavor it's this it's not the
salty flavor
is it i don't even know if it's popcorn
give me some what is it in cracker juice
peanuts okay some peanuts boom
and crackers they're not peanuts
salted salted biscuits salted buddy they
come in the shells
you're talking about you talk about
apple pie then you're associating it to
baseball meanwhile it's peanuts
and popcorn at a baseball game salt salt
hot dog loaded with soda the word hot
dog ain't in that song buddy i got news
for you and those peanuts are
got shells on them do i feel like the
right cinnamon raisin
at the right time at the right
temperature with the right amount of
butter can be feel like a hug
a warm hug yeah let me take it let me
but i'm not even arguing that let me i'm
saying that
a cinnamon raisin bagel is a once in a
while bagel and everything bagel
is like pizza you can eat it every day
every time and if
if if only one bagel had to exist for
the rest of my life
the most versatile fun inclusive bagel
is the everything it's in the name
all three major where are we
anglos what time are we at four minutes
left all three major
anglo-saxon holidays
[Laughter]
you think of cinnamon halloween
thanksgiving
and christmas halloween yeah cinnamon
apples and halloween
uh pies caramel apples cinnamon too
it's just like caramel pies i never say
caramel i say caramel apple cider with
cinnamon sprinkled on it
uh thanksgiving yes thanksgiving 100
with the pies christmas okay
thanksgiving christmas christmas eggnog
all three easter is even
associated with candy and sweets not
nothing salty all right
that's my point okay uh i don't see
cinnamon
at halloween at all i don't associate
those apples if anything i associate
salt or cider with cinnamon sprinkled on
it on halloween
yes you're describing a thanksgiving
drink no no hold on
you you got to pull your head out of
your ass right now because look i
i appreciate that argument but then you
have to get greedy and throw halloween
in there
cinnamon no one's like halloween apple
cider with cinnamon
you never saw apple cider with a
cinnamon stick in it yes
apple cider is for thanksgiving no apple
cider is huge at halloween are you
kidding me that's when it hits the show
mike google apple cider halloween please
well
but you get good apple cider my freaking
left foot it's gonna come
out what i said about the blood thing
and i was wrong we didn't find blood
bagels
it's a big halloween thing i'm telling
you they that's what it drops every year
that's the record release party well i
will say
i will say pumpkin i associate with
halloween and do people put cinnamon and
i think you're thinking pumpkin pie you
know what i think you can have nutmeg i
think nutmeg look at that halloween
apple cider skulls thing that's clearly
got something
i never i never associated apples oh
nutmeg goes on you're right nutmeg goes
on um uh eggnog it's nutmeg
yeah cinnamon christmas is cinnamon
cinnamon apples oh christmas is cinnamon
all the way i'm not taking it from you
thanksgiving you know what i made last
christmas cinnamon a [ __ ] goose
and i made some cinnamon apples to go
with what is it what a goose
a goose what is that like they did in
charles dickens you did not
yes i did i i found a goose and i made
it who sells goose
it was hard to find my friend it was not
easy how did you know
it was a gamey uh yeah
why yeah because i wanted to make a
christmas goose
because i'd heard about it my whole life
so you bought it like we buy chicken
like you didn't like chop the head off i
had to go to a chef
at a restaurant and say get me a goose
and he got me a goose from his game
poultry were you home for the holidays
tell me tell me didn't cook a goose
alone
no i woke up yeah but they wanted a
goose
it sounds very very unappealing it
doesn't sound appetizing like if i look
at a menu i'm not like oh
goose oh tastes like duck this is
expensive bird duck is not good either
i love duck all right listen this this
might be another you might have just
witnessed another episode be born
i'll go to the mat for duck oh no no no
no
okay let's save it tell us your results
this guy is all about duck duck goose
that's it don't waste it don't waste it
all right let's go to the mat
we're going to the polls it's time for
humble pie right now where somebody gets
to eat
because they spent a half hour making a
fool of them
here we go i should have called
i called another drumming i said it
would be a bigger margin before i look
i said it would be a big an even bigger
margin of defeat
than oriole beat the chips ahoy he's
gonna reveal it on the screen
oh please do oh never mind
all right okay here we go
the winner by a bigger margin
then oreo chips ahoy at 64.36 who do you
think won joe
judging from your arrogance everything
bagels
everything bagel 64 to 36 that's an even
bigger defeat than episode one
okay again michael bigly is saying now
you're just being a dick what is he
everything he agreed he's he's he's like
we're just
being insulting i'll go heckle him in
his next broadway show
what he says i'll throw cinnamon raisin
bagels out all right
from the audience the uh and i i and i
will do that
you know yeah i don't care no that's how
i retire from this place it's a nice
taste buds taste buds gorilla marketing
i will to quote uh super hands
who's my favorite character from one of
my favorite tv shows ever peep show
never ever listen to the public
the public likes coldplay and voted for
hitler
[Laughter]
so i still think i'm on the right side
of history i'll i'll read off some uh
some commentary
uh okay i can't answer this what is the
spread
give me some butter with cinnamon and
cream cheese with everything so let's
put in the room now
on rare occasion i eat a bagel it has to
be an everything bagel
okay uh won't eat anything with raisins
they look like cat turds
raisins another person raisins look like
dead flies without wings
i go for everything look at this psycho
up here this is who you're dealing with
on your team
this guy actually parmesan with
salsa cream cheese one of the most
disgusting things i could even imagine
that and cranberry orange then on an
everything
that is revolting that's revolt i love a
cranberry orange muffin so i can't apply
it there
that's another great thing about taste
buds is that uh we when we pull
we you if you're watching and you're
playing along and everything you
you have there's very well that we could
read your comments
on the uh the podcast uh here we go um
here we go
the one that that's up there right now
with the
gif that's really can you read it
cinnamon raisin is the shredded wheat of
bagels
like the regular kind not even frosted
[ __ ] out of here with that
and then that hurts that gift is
hysterical yeah
that passion is how i feel about the
everything
this is what i want to say to you yeah
that clip is hysterical
i got to use that gif everything bagels
every time and i make my own at home now
um damn i'm stuck here i've never even
tried an everything bagel
cinnamon raisin with apple butter
there's a lot of people you know what
happens here people want to just give
their own they veer from what i'm asking
i know then they oh well pimento
all right honey walnut all right
i saw i did see a cinnamon raisin all
day long there it is i've seen that
salmon raisin all day long
um
everything bagel i do not acknowledge
that first choice
this lady writes i love olive pimento
cream
this is a [ __ ] show listen it's
disgusting everything bagels
everything bagels are my life nothing
was ever made better
by adding raisins to it oh man i wish i
would have had that line diane
that's insane no that's not that's all
you know it's not that's you are not
okay uh
why doesn't in everything have cinnamon
raisin
wow great question because you can't do
that because the cinnamon raisin
is just you can't have it all the time
you can't combine the two
no because it supports my argument that
only a lunatic
puts sweet [ __ ] on an everything bagel
cinnamon bagels period are the best
unless it's with taylor ham egg and
cheese
oh that's philly all the way there yeah
that's jersey yeah
uh yeah i mean i mean look
i'm reading both cinnamon raisin i don't
want garlic
breath best bagel is an egg oh you can
take you could go take a walk you on
raisins ruin everything hangovers and
everything everything 100 not even a
question
anything with raisins is inferior to
anything without
hey can we make this the last anything
raisin is
vile had meat cinnamon lost me at raisin
what psycho is this that's finding just
cinnamon bagels somewhere
i've never even heard of such a thing
somebody screen capped it
at one vote and said this settles it and
it was 100
everything on the first vote but i mean
you know i like to read off both because
i like to you know
we like to do both sides of the coin
here we're fair here at taste buds
but i will say people i mean large
groups of people are repulsed by raisins
i had no idea i don't get it but uh joe
they're not i think they think they're
prunes they're not prunes they're raised
no i don't think they think that you're
saying that you think people who can
read and are
not capable people are reading the word
raisins and thinking they're prunes
they're thinking they're dried plums
that are ten times the size people in
here that think there's just
cinnamon bagels out there somewhere you
think those people think those are
prunes on the bagel
joe you're grabbing at straws the boat
is now under women and children get off
all right i still love you i love you
too buddy i love you too
yeah our next episode
our next one's going to be a hot one uh
so
come back for it uh that's the show uh
my other podcast without a country
me and corinne fisher discussing the
news uh every
week on gas digital network use the
promo code wac when you subscribe get a
free 30 days
uh live stream every tuesday night on
gas digital exclusively and then it hits
everywhere you get your podcast from for
free on saturdays
and then pat walsh and myself reviewing
movies on the we'll see you in l podcast
uh back catalog available wherever you
get your podcasts
and new episodes on patreon only
i love it i love it i gotta i gotta
watch so i've been meaning to watch some
of those
you're busy with these things jesus uh
it's not crazy yeah it's two day one it
feels like a lot one day a week for me
and corinne's and then
one two days a month for me and pat now
this will be another day a month and
yeah
it's not that bad yeah but it's a lot of
content that's good yeah you're working
better i'm enjoying
i like doing this stuff man i'm enjoying
it more than
like this is five stars we were doing
that just like we were doing this anyway
yeah which is so funny like literally
this entire conversation probably
happened already
that was the same conversation yeah yeah
yeah i got uh
the hey babe podcast with chris stefano
uh also on this channel and uh
the tv shows are coming back on soon um
we had to stop down but we got some good
news that they're all
uh coming back up and that's dinner
party and misery index and jokers and
then if this
happens to have not come out by august
22nd or it comes out before august 22nd
i will be in the cape cod drive-in doing
some stand-up that night that's saturday
always want to take a tickets at
salvolcanocomedy.com
[Music]
you